[Music]
i would think there might be
disadvantages to not being able to hear
if you're
riding a motorcycle professionally
needing to
hear the the shifting of the engine hear
other racers coming up on either side of
you i mean i would think it would be a
disadvantage
yeah for sure it's um it's a little a
disadvantage you know i can't hear them
obviously so i have to hold my line i
can't move around on the track us i'll
hit them
it's a advantage off the track because i
can't hear them talking trash about me
or anything like that
it works out good
[Applause]
i'm very happy about that
uh you are uh five feet two inches tall
do you is that a a problem when you're
riding these bikes are very powerful
these bikes are very fast and they're
big machines is that a disadvantage in
the sport
yeah it definitely is a disadvantage you
know i'm only five two of course i weigh
a hundred pounds
i ride a motorcycle that's 200 pounds so
you know trying to hold the bike when
it's really on a rough track it gets
difficult so
um but it's an advantage on the start
because i'm so light that i can get out
front so that really helps me
okay you uh you now you uh race
women
uh exclusively but you're interested you
would like to race guys is that true
yeah for sure i always wanted to race
with men i grew up raising boys and i
think i can do it
when
i think you can too
i know you can
when you were younger you had pink hair
and you still have something here but
you had bright pink hair and you liked
it when you raced against boys you liked
having pink hair why
yeah of course i've always loved pink
hair so i've been little and you know i
wanted my first national with pink hair
and i always thought it was good luck
for me and you know it doesn't hurt when
you pass a boy with pink hair
[Laughter]
they know they've been passed yeah
uh you were knocked unconscious in a
crash before the
2011 x games and you could not compete
what does that do to your attitude
this year does it make you is it give
you more fear
or in a way does it make you more
determined
no i'm definitely more motivated this
year i'm gonna come back and i'm gonna
be ready to win a gold medal my third
one and i'm ready yeah this is i'm gonna
do my best that's all i can really do
all right
that's i don't worry about you
can i ask you jim do you
you uh grew up racing you raced for a
long time your dad raised for a long
time uh do you are you comfortable
watching ashley race now as a young
woman or is it difficult for you to
watch is it scary yeah i mean i grew up
doing it my dad um i've watched ashley
do it um but no it's not something that
you ever get comfortable with you know
it's something that i mean that's my kid
i love my kid i want her to be safe so
um
you know i get nervous just like anybody
else and i want the best for but
actually when the gate drops i like go
get them you know so this the the fear
goes away and you know but of course you
know i'm always concerned with it i
never get comfortable with that yeah all
right well absolute joy having you on
the show thank you so much for being
here
yeah
great
it's a great story best of luck to you